Global warming is happening because humans have altered the Earth's atmosphere...
...so the heat cannot escape from it.
We need some heat, of course.
Carbon dioxide, methane and water vapor retain enough heat from the sun...
...to sustain life on Earth.
But human activity has disrupted that balance.
We've put carbon dioxide, methane...
...and nitrous oxide into the atmosphere in massive amounts by burning fossil fuel,...
...oil, gas and coal.
We've cut down a lot of forests...
...and use farming methods that add to the greenhouse gases in the atmosphere.
Now, there's too much carbon dioxide, methane and nitrous oxide in the air.
Today, the atmosphere contains 32 percent more carbon dioxide than it did in the mid-1800s.
All those gases act like a blanket retaining too much of the sun's heat.
That means we're fundamentally changing planet Earth's climate.
Global average temperature has risen by .6-degree Celsius since 1900.
The Northern Hemisphere is now substantially warmer...
...than at any point during the past 1,000 years.
And that is global warming.